What the hell do you want?
Teach me.
Think about it:...
...the blue one, you teach me and you get to live your secret life in peace,...
...the red one, I'll tell everyone that you're not dead.
Why do you wanna play like me?
You're voted Rock Guitar's Guitarist in 1993.
I don't wanna ever hear another word about me.
You gotta find your own voice.
Take me to the Battle of the Bands next week.
You realize you can't even look at an audience?
You just play.
He's got more talent than you'll ever have.
Don't play anything you don't feel.
Ladies and gentlemen, artist of the year,...
...Tom!
You are gonna be great.
He's lonely down there, he just needs a bit of love.
Mom!
God's love.
Rock and roll, baby!